Brian asks should I post articles on my
blog and mention on social or post
natively on sites like LinkedIn medium
and Facebook or both Brian great
question and it's a loaded question
right because you've probably looked at
the new garyvaynerchuk.com and you
probably realize that I'm doing a mix
right like you know you land on that
page and I've got the place for medium
posts and LinkedIn posts when you land
on it some of the posts literally link
out to LinkedIn medium and then
obviously I have my own post and
actually Steve and I were just talking
did we put up the first post where it's
just for garyvaynerchuk.com got it so
that's there too and so what I think is
interesting about this question is most
people in the internet marketing world
want to keep telling you to do it on
your own site monetize your own traffic
it's yours
Facebook reach can't take be taken away
all this own it own it own it
the problem with own it own it own it is
when you're doing it on your own site
you're at the mercy of how much traffic
you're able to establish on your own
site and so for the 99.999% of you that
are watching this that don't have 4
million unique people coming to your
site every day every month the reality
is this place is like medium for example
I had a medium go extremely viral by you
know viral Azzam it did really well on
medium and right now it's sitting as
number six or seven on mediums top
stories where I've noticed that 950
people have clicked over and read the
article because of that place and that's
950 people that I'm gonna guess 787 of
them have never even heard of me before
and so too many people are worried about
monetizing them now posting on their
page versus using things like LinkedIn
and medium and notice I use those two
because they have viral leaps LinkedIn
when articles go well it shows up in
pulse medium get sends out an email and
has the top stories so I like being in
places where there's viral loops that if
you put out a nice piece of content I
noticed a kid on Twitter today tweet out
hey I'm number four on medium two spots
ahead of Gary Vee and then I looked at
his profile and he has 1400 Twitter
followers and that got me excited I'm
like see great content can raise to the
top and bring awareness and so I think a
head
mix of both I'm a big fan of picking
spots repeatedly that give you awareness
and then builds leverage for you that
then eventually you can monetize in your
own world